when people haven't seen the show and
they say oh you want to show Outlander
season 3 what's it about how do you
break it down in the most simplistic way
possible yeah and watch the show
yeah watch a movie out yeah season may I
mean it's always been a difficult show
to describe but I think this season may
be the hardest one yet to describe I
think so gets even more complicated well
yeah because you know we start off our
season our both our main characters
their storylines are separate well two
of the main through of the storylines
separate and then the show and then we
go through 20 years then the show goes
on a very strange journey I guess it's a
show of transition but we spend some
time in Scotland and then we we cross
the Atlantic and we end up in the New
World
and lots of crazy crazy things happen
along the way but I don't know how to
make that into two senses is it a roller
coaster because are you live are you
dead are you coming back are you going
to disappear I don't know what I'm
saying
yes was that yes
the main thing I'm doing in this is
Frank in the we go to Boston and see
Frank and Claire trying to rebuild their
marriage and Breanna arrives and to the
whole 20 years of that and yeah so
that's my main involvement and yeah it
was really great to kind of dig into all
that
and add some great to be back in a on a
soundstage with with cat and you know
kind of kicking ten bells out of each
other yeah yeah it gets pretty feisty
yeah it's a slice in there how do you I
mean how do you dig into a character
like that who is obviously in a
relationship who has she's in love with
somebody else kind of but comes back but
you're liable you did how do you wrap
your head around a character like that
um well I mean I think Frank I'm not
necessarily even sure he entirely
believes you know the story on its face
value I think he chooses to accept it
but that's you know in order to move
forward and have Claire back and build a
life yeah I mean there's lots of them
compromises yes it's a relationship
built on confines is choosing to sort of
focus on certain things not here other
things that's in a way that whole part
of the story is like an antidote to the
more kind of romantic catechol of that
extreme Jamie and Claire this is about
kind of something called compromise much
more kind of practical almost but no
more no less kind of no less romantic or
maybe no less heroic what they managed
to achieve they raised a child and do
that successfully and despite all the
kind of complications and difficulties
does it change the way for either of you
in actuality just the idea of it changes
the way you look at maybe love and
soulmates make you think what that about
you're in actual real life okay yeah um
I don't know more romantic and I don't
know that it's it's really changed how I
viewed I'm still a hard Infinit yes well
you know I think I think the thing about
Claire and Jamie is that's that that's
the aspirational thing you know that's
the thing that everyone wants to believe
is possible and you know I think the
thing is Claire and Frank almost feels
more real and more was a lot of people
get to experience but
I would say it was contrary to what
Tobias says I would say I'm pretty
romantic person and I believe in love so
I say that that's still possible no
offense okay but a lot of people online
and around the world want you to be with
Jamie yeah they want called a fantasy do
you feel like that's part of the appeal
of the show if there's fantasy mix with
actuality well yeah I mean you know I
think that's sort of what I was trying
to say is that you know for most people
who watch the show or other shows
they're looking for a little bit of
escapism and a little bit of you have no
hope that these you know fantastical
love conquers all situations are
possible and you know I hope for most
people they are but unfortunately you
know life's tough disappointments are at
every corner and I think that people are
really rooting for ya the the perfect
relationship because it's maybe contrary
to what they have themselves speaking of
relationships being tough we see Jamie
we think kissing another girl oh I am
Anna knows with the kisses Owen to kiss
another girl kissing of the German oh is
that something will start to see woven
and named of the plot line of upcoming
season can exist anything about that
might be another girl involved let's
just say that he he's not a monk for 20
years okay so you know there may be some
little situations that happen but you
know he's a man who can who can blame
him 20 years is a long time is a long
time between the 50s how are you were
you aware of how much this show I mean a
you know there's there's Outlander
conventions without actors where people
just talk about the plot lines and stuff
were you aware of how monumentally how
strong the following was or what this
show would do to your lives I'm not a
betting man mostly I would
before I got involved ya know some been
part of the magical adventure he said no
but do you know I think I think that
that you know had you known that it was
so so massive and so passionate you know
I think maybe when we began season one
maybe there would have been extra
pressure but I think we all sort of
walked into it with a nice dose of
naivete and completely yeah and that
allowed us to really find these
characters in our own way and you know
not have the expectations kind of forced
upon us and I think that that's really
helped us going forward right yeah yeah
having had some weird apparently I would
abandon as you had some weird
experiences with fans great it yeah
great I mean we have amazing fans
they're very passionate and they love
the stories and they're great so
defenders of the story they like but
thus far we haven't gotten on the wrong
side of them I think they are happy and
excited by what we're doing with it and
know they generally give us a lot of
encouragement I love yeah you know you
know Steve love come out yours really
really awesome and you know we all sort
of have charities that we work with and
you know the amount of generosity this
can really write know oh my god I'm not
you know that's something that you just
don't expect going into something like
this is that you can pay it forward or
help pay it forward and in a really
beneficial way and that's been the
coolest thing and that's all the funds
you know I remember talking about the
Casa blast for example and they were
saying people would come up to them and
say how did you get off the island can
they be not just a television show
yeah I'm not into him that bad no no
nothing Diana says this really great
thing she says you know the fans of the
books or they usually have to be able to
read you know eight hundred pages at
least per book so this is there's a lot
of halogens and fans of selecting groups
ya know we're we're pretty lucky with
our our crew no one's come up and said
what are you doing here you're supposed
to be 17 whatever where's your red coat
yeah yeah
do you know the arc of your character if
you because you're dead alive we
continue to the whole season can you
give us anything like that do you see I
don't mean how long can the show go on
she can ask that name how long can the
show go I mean how long was Diana keep
writing
yeah she's got a book yeah I think the
91 is do you at some point
soonish I mean might Outland you sir it
is possible and yeah she's my major food
Diana look a lot better than I do
for my age you know she's missin she's a
she's a force of nature I'm not certain
that she's a hundred percent human
actually yes you might maybe she's a ton
maybe she maybe the time travel all the
way she'll come from that's Africa